125 millions d'euros investis dans un
plan d'action de 13 mesures
osez l'export a été présenté hier jeudi
31 août par Olivier best ministre
délégué au Commerce extérieur c'est
surtout la capacité d'aller chercher les
patrons de PME pour les pousser à
l'export nous en avons fondamentalement
besoin nous avons pas assez
d'entreprises exportatrices en France
c'est dommage pour le pays parce que
quand on importe plus que l'on exporte
en fait on appauvrit le pays parmi les
sociétés qui pourraient en bénéficier et
Mitek l'entreprise énigmate spécialisée
dans les essais d'équipements
électroniques c'est ouverte à l'étranger
il y a une dizaine d'années l'export
représente aujourd'hui 11% de son
activité on ne peut plus travailler sans
export on a des moyens colossaux qui
dépassent les capacités de l'industrie
française et qu'il faut donc chercher de
nouveaux clients nous avons travaillé
avec Ferrari Opel jaguar Land Rover etc
parmi les 13 mesures parlementaires pour
l'export donnez un rôle clé aux député
sénateur pour inciter les entreprises
dans le département Marie le bec député
de la quatrième circonscription et
Charles Rodwell de la première
circonscription sur mobilisées objectif
passer de 150 000 à 200 000 le nombre
d'entreprises exportatrices